nous sommes avec l'autre blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
tout d'abord quelle impression globale
se dégage de ce grand oral cette année
le projet de la billie routine
manifestement très à l'aise pendant plus
de 3 heures 40 durant lesquelles il a
répondu à une centaine de questions de
russes c'est le dix huitième exercice
annuel de ce genre et il est
particulièrement à l'aise avec ces
questions dont la plupart portent sur la
politique intérieure ce qui préoccupe
véritablement le citoyen russe c'est ce
qui le préoccupe c'est d'abord le coût
de la vie et à cela la drire poutine
répond mais la banque centrale vient de
hausser ses taux directeurs de façon à
réduire le niveau de l'inflation qui
doit passer dans les prochains mois qui
doit être réduite 2% de deux points dans
les prochains mois pour la hausse des
prix alimentaires le gouvernement a pris
et va prendre des mesures pour limiter
cette hausse
même chose pour la hausse des produits
de la construction
et puis pour le reste et bien
généralement et cette année encore les
intervenants qui pose des questions
pointe du doigt un manquement des
autorités locales
par exemple une une personne dit mais
pourquoi est ce que la location que j'ai
tous touchés pour élever mon enfant qui
est dans un âge entre entre 4 et 7 ans
eh bien je ne la touche plus on me dit
localement que c'est parce que je ne
peux pas démontré que j'ai eu 12 mois de
salaire l'année précédente et bien
entendu à cause du que vit la cause du
chômage
il est évident que je ne peux pas des me
fait ces démonstrations et le président
poutine répond mais c'est illégal et à
ce moment là les oreilles du gouverneur
local doivent siffler et c'est comme ça
à chaque année puisque effectivement les
questions posées dès les
les pousses doigt sur des manquements
des autorités locales qui sort mal
interprété la loi fédérale soit non pas
appliquer des directives
gouvernementales
donc c'est utile c'est utile pour les
citoyens est aussi utile pour le
président parce que ça lui permet de
voir quelles sont les préoccupations de
la population et aussi de voir dans
quelle mesure les directives globales
sont appliquées dans les différentes
régions donc c'est sans doute une
épreuve un petit peu difficile pendant
quatre heures pour les gouverneurs des
différentes régions en tout cas vladimir
poutine a été très clair sur sa volonté
de vacciner le plus possible la
population
il faut vacciner et là dessus vladimir
poutine a tenu le même langage que
beaucoup d'autres chefs d'état et de
gouvernement il faut vacciner bien
entendu massivement lui-même a dit qu'il
avait été vacciné les mois de février
avec le vaccin spotnicks vais bien
entendu et que comme les forces armées
comme beaucoup de monde en russie
simplement il ya une certaine réticence
d'une partie de la population russe et
peut-être d'ailleurs une partie de cette
réticence est dû au fait que à l'époque
soviétique
les vaccinations était obligatoire
c'est-à-dire poutine a souligné le fait
qu'elles ne sont plus obligatoires et
que dans la loi votée en 1804 mineurs en
1998 par la douma
eh bien il ya des vaccinations
obligatoires mais d'autres qui ne le
sont pas ça c'est pour la glff fédéral
il a vivement encouragé les autorités
locales c'est-à-dire les gouverneurs les
maires des grandes villes à rendre
obligatoire cette vaccination pour
certaines professions naturellement sauf
contre indication médicale
alors si vladimir poutine voulait rendre
la vaccination obligatoire il le
pourrait il ferait voter une nouvelle
loi à la douma
mais manifestement ce n'est pas le cas
il tient à ce que les choses seraient
ajustés localement par les autorités
locales
peut-être aussi faire porter assez
largement la responsabilité sur ces
autorités locales alors la vaccination
le porte parole du kremlin
curieusement a dit hier que ne serait
pas possible d'atteindre l'immunité à
l'automne du c'est-à-dire delevaque la
vaccination de 60% de la population
serait il faudrait un temps plus long
probablement à la fin de l'année le
dossier ukrainien comme le disait verra
également au menu de ce grand oral et
avec le président volodymyr rosen ce qui
veut dire poutine a réagi à quoi bon
nous rencontrer le dialogue est pour
ainsi dire ont pu alors il n'a pas
beaucoup d'appétit pour rencontrer et
volodymyr zenasci c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire qu'il rencontrait
cependant son prédécesseur le président
porochenko qui avaient des positions
pro-occidentales puisqu'après tout c'est
pour auch échos qui a fait un gain secr
ire dans la constitution que l'ukraine
devrait rentrer dans le temps chacun
sait que pour vladimir poutine c'est une
ligne rouge et il a d'ailleurs signifié
à joe biden la semaine dernière à genève
alors quels sont les les défauts de
monsieur hainard ce qui aux yeux du
président russe
il est possible que ce soit le fait que
en effet la campagne contre la langue
russe se poursuit en ukraine et que
volodymyr un zèle 1 ce qui ne se bat pas
pour faire reconnaître le russe la
langue et la culture russes comme une
langue et une culture minoritaire à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine
c'est un point qui pourtant pourrait
être discuté par le président russe et
par le président ukrainien suppose il a
dit clairement qu'ils ne voulaient pas
discuter avec eux d'un ce qui bien sûr
de la crimée mais pas du donbass non
plus puisque le donbass
c'est quelque chose qui relève de
l'application des accords de minsk et
que ces accords on sait que les
l'interprétation que vadimir poutine
leur donne il faut que monsieur menace
qui discute avec les autorités de fait
de louhansk et de dawn est à la fois du
régime d'autonomie et des conditions de
déroulement des élections dans ces deux
provinces et monsieur evans qui ne veut
pas le faire dans les conditions
actuelles
et je voudrais d'abord qui récupère est
le contrôle de la frontière avec la
russie ce qui n'est pas acceptable pour
moscou où on en est toujours là et il
est possible que monsieur et l'inscrit
monsieur poutine se rencontrent dans
quelques mois
mais monsieur poutine veut clairement
établir
que ce serait pour discuter des
relations entre kiev et moscou est pas
du nom basse et évidemment on le disait
aussi un la relation avec les états unis
après la rencontre à genève entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine les réponses
aujourd'hui du président russe sur sa
relation avec les américains qui indique
une détente amorcée
alors je crois que son explication est
une explication à destination du grand
public russe voilà les américains
continuent à se comporter comme la plus
grande puissance mondiale
alors qu'ils sont menacés sur ce plan
par la chine mais tous les observateurs
s'accordent à reconnaître que la semaine
dernière à genève
joe biden a de fait une avancée
importante en direction de la russie en
lui reconnaissant qu' elle était la
terreur stratégiques nucléaires naturel
des états unis pour la bonne raison que
les deux pays détiennent 90% des têtes
nucléaires et des missiles pour les
délivrer par conséquent ils ont la
responsabilité de l'absence d'une guerre
nucléaire et de la stabilité mondiale
sur ce point mais joe biden a avancé un
nouveau point qui est le point de la
cyberguerre il a très clairement dit à
vladimir poutine que si des objectifs
stratégiques civils ou militaires
étaient atteints aux états unis et bien
il y aurait des représailles
avec des moyens beaucoup plus puissant
autrement dit pour les états unis
aujourd'hui
la cyberguerre devient quelque chose qui
est important parce qu'on ne sait pas
quelles sont les règles de la dissuasion
dans la cyber-guerre pour le moment il
n'y a pas de dissuasion et que c'est par
ce biais d'une attaque cyber attribué à
un état avec ou sans preuve
en tout cas quelques fois avec des
présomptions des représailles des
représailles représailles et par
conséquent une escalade dans laquelle on
pourrait se diriger vers un véritable
conflit est le deuxième groupe de
travail qui a été convenu à genève
et précisément destinée à traiter de ce
sujet quelles règles peloton peut-on
établir dans ce domaine d'autant plus
que les cyber attaques peuvent être
faites par des état relativement peu
puissant et il s'agit pas uniquement les
états unis de la russie l'un comme
l'autre peuvent être victimes d'attaqués
cyber et peut-être vous retrouvez un
intérêt commun à s'en protéger
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales